Eine technische Zeichnung wird natürlich für das Atelier
oder die Produktionsstätte gemacht,
die dann das Kleidungsstück auch herstellt und diese
benötigt natürlich meist noch mehr Angaben.
Oftmals haben wir dann ein ganzes Dossier mit verschiedenen
Papieren und Dateien die Informationen über das
Kleidungsstück geben,
wie zum Beispiel auch eine Maßtabelle oder Angaben,
wie das Ganze genäht werden soll.
Ich würde dir jetzt empfehlen,
erst mal deine Arbeit nochmal zu speichern und dann über
Speichern unter eine zweite Datei anzulegen,
auf der ich dann genauer detaillierte Angaben machen würde.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt eine Datei mit unserer
Grundzeichnung und legen jetzt noch eine zweite an mit
Detailangaben.
Die kannst du jetzt zum Beispiel unter technische
Zeichnungen, Rock, Detailangaben abspeichern.
So jetzt würde ich erstmal die Schablone rauslöschen,
die brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr,
also eben entsperren und die Schablone vorne und hinten
rauslöschen.
Du könntest dir jetzt noch eine dritte Zeichenfläche
anlegen, wenn du möchtest,
um eine Übersicht über das Modell zu geben und Vorderteil
und Hinterteil zusammen zu platzieren.
Das ist jetzt auch die Seite,
wo ich Angaben machen würde zum entsprechenden Stoff
oder zum Reißverschluss oder Knöpfen oder sonstigen Sachen,
die gebraucht werden um diesen Rock zu produzieren.
Wenn du also schon weißt,
was du hier für einen Stoff benutzen möchtest,
könntest du dir hier ein kleines Textfeld anlegen und das
entsprechend eintragen.
Ich würde das jetzt auch nochmal optisch trennen,
nochmal mit dem Linienwerkzeug mir hier ein Segment anlegen
und dort meine Informationen eintragen.
So und jetzt habe ich noch mein Vorderteil und mein Rückteil
und kann hier Detailangaben machen.
Dazu gehst du jetzt auf die Zeichenfläche mit entsprechend
Vorderteil oder Rückteil.
Ich würde jetzt die Zeichnung auch
so ein bisschen an die Seite platzieren und dann die andere
Seite dafür nutzen, meine Angaben zu machen,
damit es auch wirklich übersichtlich ist.
Es gibt auch ganz oft Zeichnungen,
wo die technische Zeichnung in der Mitte ist und dann Pfeile
überall hingehen und das Ganze ist dann aber meistens sehr
unübersichtlich.
Denkt immer daran, dass die Person,
die dann euer Kleidungsstück herstellt,
sich gut zurechtfinden muss und es wirklich schwierig ist
dann in allen Richtungen irgendwas zu lesen und zu wissen,
habe ich das jetzt schon abgearbeitet oder nicht.
Deshalb also meine Empfehlung,
technische Zeichnung auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen
Seite habe ich dann meine Detailangaben.
Dazu möchte ich Pfeile verwenden.
Um einen Pfeil zu gestalten,
nutzt du zunächst das Liniensegment.
Du kannst jetzt hier von dem Punkt,
den du beschriften möchtest,
bis zu der anderen Seite eine Linie ziehen.
Drück dabei die Shift-Taste, damit diese Linie gerade
Ist.
Jetzt kannst du beim Bedienfeld Eigenschaften auf Kontur
klicken und kannst hier einen Pfeil anlegen.
Du kannst entweder die Pfeilspitze vorne an der Linie
anlegen oder hinten.
Ich lege sie jetzt hinten an,
sodass mein Pfeil von dem Punkt, ich beschreiben möchte,
zu dem Text
Zeigt.
So, jetzt kann ich diesen Pfeil dann auch beliebig
oft kopieren.
Anstatt mir ständig einen neuen Pfeil zu basteln und lege
jetzt auch noch ein Textfeld an, um das Ganze dann zu
Beschriften.
Auf dem Vorderteil haben wir Abnäher,
wir haben eine Tasche und wir haben den Saum und den
Bund, den wir beschriften können.
Hier können wir zum Beispiel angeben,
wie lang der Abnäher sein soll oder wir können angeben,
dass es in der Tasche innen noch eine Absteppung gibt.
Da könnten wir zum Beispiel beschreiben,
dass diese Absteppung 0,5 cm von der Naht
entfernt liegt.
Das gleiche auch für den Bund,
denn da sehen wir auch diese Absteppung auf dem Rückteil.
Für den Saum könnten wir jetzt beschreiben,
ob es da innen eine unsichtbare Naht gibt.
Wenn wir das für das Vorderteil alles angelegt haben,
können wir das Gleiche auch für das Rückteil tun.
Hier könnten wir zum Beispiel angeben,
was wir für einen Reißverschluss benutzen,
wie lang der ist und wir könnten angeben,
wie lang der Schlitz ist.
Wenn du jetzt alle Angaben gemacht hast,
die für dich wichtig sind,
sind wir fertig mit unserer technischen Zeichnung und den
Detailangaben.